les accus et en marge des rencontres
sportives diverses dont nous allons
parler bien sûr à la fin de ce journal
un match de rugby très spécial s'est
déroulée hier soir à bayonne 5000
spectateurs étaient venus là pour
soutenir l'action de patrice lagisquet
en faveur des enfants trisomiques et en
faveur de l'association chrysalide
c'était ce que l'on appelle une bonne
action et ce qui ne gâte rien au
contraire cela s'est déroulé dans la
bonne humeur jean louis normand de milan
joue derniers essayages
bon ben on veut lui tout enrobé de vert
et rose le showbiz pétillent et jean
baptiste lafond s'adonnera frappe
impeccable premier sorti en damier noir
et blanc discutent tranquillement les
barbares riant les chaussettes ne se
cache plus même brennus sur son bouclier
a fait le voyage sur la côte basque
d'ailleurs denis charvet a retrouvé le
short du valeureux chef gaulois un short
qui selon les anciens auraient été
utilisées lors d'un match mémorable
entre le 15 gaulois et l'équipe de césar
en 300 ans avant jésus-christ
au pied des remparts les bandas se donne
de la voix fêtes de bayonne oblige entré
en musique des joueurs sur le stade
parmi les 5000 spectateurs des enfants
de l'association chrysalide qui
regardent d'intrigués de bien-être en
tango et chevaucher
patrice lagisquet et son association
chrysalide peuvent avoir le sourire
quinze essais et surtout 150 mille
francs récoltés de quoi faciliter bien
des projets